all right welcome to advanced workflows
functions I appreciate everyone coming
to the last session of the day I was a
little bit concerned about jet lag but
it's actually morning where I'm from so
I'm waking up right now so it's perfect
timing if you're here about nine hours
ago for the keynote there was a mention
of 1982 sort of a magical year where mr.
Neal was introduced to computers that's
about the same time that this game came
out and something that left a huge
impression on me it's a text-based
adventure game you can tell from the
packaging though they really spun quite
quite a visual there you can see the
sort of skull you can see the castle you
can see the imagery of the dungeon and
this is when I visited the catacombs in
Paris and it was how I visualized as a
kid playing the game that would be a
dungeon and back then we had to have a
huge imagination because this is
actually what the game looked like right
so well it was it exactly as the the
cover promised but I want to use this as
some context to relate what I'm going to
talk about just really briefly a little
bit about myself I'm a cloud advocate at
Microsoft if you're not sure what that
means feel free to stop me afterwards
I'll be happy to explain it we've got so
many terms in the industry right now
it's hard to keep up with that I've been
professionally developing for a capital
really long time so I'll just leave it
at that I've written a few history books
I think I released a Silverlight 5 book
about two weeks before everyone figured
out that I was going to die and I
released the windows runtime book just a
few weeks before that platform shifted
and so as a result of that legacy I have
a lot of developers asked me to write a
book about JavaScript so figured that
out so it was a former MVP I joined
Microsoft so you can't be an MVP in that
Microsoft I try to follow a hundred
percent plant-based diet but I'm sure
that something in the food supply sneaks
in there so I say it slightly less and
this is how you can get in touch with me
either through Twitter or direct through
email happy to take
your feedback and suggestions just a fun
fact I'm actually my ancestors are from
Norway they came from a town called
licinus with one s and I guess at Ellis
Island an extra s was added this is my
first time in Norway so I plan to come
back and visit that town what I want to
cover today is level sake get on the
same page of serverless as one of those
terms
we can't take for granted because no one
can agree on what it means
talk about durable functions hopefully
throw a lot of code out there that makes
sense
and then we'll have some time for Q&A
afterwards so the first thing we'll
tackle is what is this amazing newfound
everything should be called serverless
right so let's talk a little bit about
how we got the server lists I think a
lot of us are still familiar with the
physical servers that we own everything
this was early in my career basically
had to worry about power how to get
access how to install the operating
system how to patch keep things up to
date there's a lot of responsibility for
that a lot of late night calls a lot of
weekends keeping things up fortunately
infrastructure as a service came along
and this abstracts the hardware out and
we're pretty much responsible for the
operating system and everything on top
one of the best things that came out of
infrastructure-as-a-service courses that
pave the way to bring workloads to the
web so I can take my virtual image and I
can run that workload in the cloud then
we have platform as a service this
abstracts everything but the platform
itself so as a web developer if I'm
building a web API
I can focus on my web project and not
have to worry about maintaining the
operating system does anyone here work
with iis server out of curiosity or has
in the past so a few hands I can see
through the blur of of lighting so we
don't have to become experts at iis it's
fully managed for us so we just focus on
the web project and deploy it which is
great server lists takes that one step
further and it abstracts the platform
and we focus on the code and I'll show
you what that means in a second
I like to do a little bit of a gut check
this is not an industry defined standard
but this is what I proposed as an idea
of what separates serverless
from fully managed and the one that's
most controversial that people tend to
disagree with me on is this so I only
get billed for active in vacations I
think a lot of times what people market
as serverless is really fully managed
and the distinction here is how does the
code scale and am i paying for something
if I'm not actually using it the way as
your functions work which is a service
platform on on Azure is you're billed
based on how many times the code is
called and then you're billed for
something called a gigabit second which
I'll come back to it's it's actually
some people explain it in a complicated
way but it's pretty straightforward when
you see it graphed out this is what it
would take for a million invitations
taken up about 128 megabytes of memory
for a second each which is pretty slow
right if your function takes a second
every time to call and that's free if we
have more activity than that let's say
we go up to 5 million in the pricing
calculator it's like 4 dollars and 40
cents US so it'd be I don't know what
300 something is it Crone how do you
pronounce it anyone the local currency
Crone's all right okay yeah maybe 40
yeah that's right 40 yeah 400 people are
going man this is getting expensive
quick so why serverless the first thing
is micro billing there's potentially a
lower cost and we'll talk about that
distinctiveness in a second but if I'm
not running workloads I'm not paying
anything if I have a massive amount of
workloads I'm paying for those but I
also have a massive amount of user so
it's kind of a positive I have less
server to worry about we'll look at that
I've elasticity so the platform is
managing the scale for me and in most
cases we end up with a rapid development
lifecycle because there's features of
server lists that make it easier to
develop so as your functions is code and
events and if you're curious and you've
never seen where
the logo for as your functions came from
it's been revealed to you right here
right now the secret is out as your
functions takes a set of events and
every time I'm gonna demo a Web API
because it's the easiest thing to demo
but it does a disservice to functions to
imply that it's only API services can
run based on triggers based on events
like file uploads based on events like
messages in a queue so there's a lot of
reasons why a piece of code might be
executed that code is called it does
something one of the benefits of this
platform is most cases you can use a
language of your choice a runtime of
your choice to build that code out and
then you have side effects you have
outputs you might manipulate a database
you might return a value so that's it at
a very high-level nutshell here's an
example of a function we basically
attribute it so we're tagging this
method is going to behave as a piece of
function code then we have a trigger and
again there's multiple triggers in this
case it's in the HTTP trigger notice I'm
not setting up a web controller I'm
saying here's how I want you to call my
code letting the platform take care of
the rest
I have bindings that make it easy to
interact with other resources in this
case I have a binding for a queue and a
binding for a table and I'm using
dependency injection to have a logging
mechanism injected for me in the body of
the function
I can do something like take the trigger
and it hands off all the information I
need so I get that request object and I
can parse it out and figure out what is
the component of the request if I want
to add something to the queue I can use
that binding notice that I'm not
spinning up a new class I'm not parsing
a connection string I'm not doing
anything else but taking that attribute
that was passed in that parameter and
interacting with it and then this is an
example of me working with the table the
tables handed to me and I interact with
it so when we're working with Azure
storage the nice thing about the server
list platform and everything I'm going
to show you today
is that there's a fully capable local
environment that you can debug and run
and execute without connecting through
the cloud there's a storage emulator as
your functions are backed by storage for
things like logging and automatically
has access to things like queues and
tables that come with storage and then
there's a storage Explorer that's a
cross-platform tool that allows you to
interact with that storage both locally
and in the cloud anyone here work with
storage Explorer by the way have
familiarity so most people are familiar
with that so for those of you not
familiar with functions I want to do a
really quick demo and just do a live
creation of a function what could
possibly go wrong
I'm just going to keep the default app
I'm going to trigger it from HTTP I'm
going to make this anonymous so I don't
have to worry too much about
authentication or authorization and this
is going to spin up a new project and
it's going to create a function at a
function app can have multiple functions
in it think of a function app as a unit
of scale when your application is scaled
out it scales out at the function app
level so whatever I group into this
project is going to scale together so if
I have related logical endpoints that's
what's going to drive the decision to
make these multiple methods in a single
function app versus separate now this is
showing you what I showed you in the
slides is just basically echoing a name
back we're going to make it a little
more interesting I'm going to turn it
into a proxy then I'm basically going to
say if string is null or whitespace the
name that's passed in return new bad
request object result need the name I've
always been very thorough with my error
messages and then what I'm going to do
is something a little bit different I'm
gonna actually create a new client and
this is my favorite borrowed feature in
Visual Studio pulling the usings
automatically actually I did that
incorrectly but
get around that and then I'm going to do
a wait text equals no let's do txt var
tax equals a wait client get string
async and the name so I'm assuming that
we've passed in a valid HTTP request I'm
just saving typing and I'm going to
assume that that comes back okay and
just return the text so we're going to
go ahead and start this without
debugging so there's a little less
overhead now what this is going to do is
it's going to launch the function app
host this is a cross-platform host it'll
run on Mac on Linux and on Windows and
it's the same host that runs in Azure so
I'm getting the same experience and here
it's parsed out my function app and it
found an end point for me to interact
with so I'm just going to grab this end
point will copy that let's come over to
a web browser and paste that in so the
default paste is going to basically come
back and tell me it needs the name
that's fine this is the perfect place to
insert a shameless plug for my blog blog
Jeremy lick nice calm and it goes out in
spins and we're over conference Wi-Fi
there's probably and boom we get the
source for my blog that right now is
hosted on medium but is being migrated
to Hugo
so this HTML will be cleaned up a lot
more but that's it that's a function in
process so let's go ahead and maximize
this back and close this out so that's
just a really short demo of course I'm
not here today to talk to you about
functions I'm here to talk to you about
durable functions so setting the stage
for what I just showed you the triggers
that can invoke a function are many
these are not all the triggers these are
the most commonly used ones the bindings
that make it easy to work with
code that you put your side effects into
or update or manipulate are all so many
and the billing I talked about the
gigabit ii the billing is pretty
straightforward left to right is time
the vertical access is how much memory
and we get billed for the area under the
curve so you can imagine that if
something takes a really long time to
run under this runtime it's going to be
more expensive and there are other are
other models to host it but for the
server list consumption based model
that's how it works and also if you
consume a large amount of memory that
also raises the cost and that can help
drive some of the decisions around
whether or not you're going to use
server lists
so it's interesting is a lot of times we
have processes that are a long duration
but they're not really a lot of compute
time now the function I just showed you
I'm getting billed for the time it's
waiting for my website to return the
results and it just doesn't seem fair
that if a website is really slow that
I'm getting billed for that so that's
one of the the side effects or issues
with the functions out of the box a lot
of times we have this idea that we're
computing and then we're waiting for
something and then we compute the actual
compute is really fast
just the duration takes a longer time so
what are durable functions and how do
they help us in this scenario
well there's challenges with server list
specifically as your functions out of
the box one is that there's no state you
have to manage the state yourself so if
you're trying to do a workflow and keep
track of state and come back to things
there's a lot of effort involved things
like asynchronous dependencies then
become complex let's say I'm waiting
asynchronously for something to happen
then I get that result have another
asynchronous that's either going to be
long-running or you're going to be
jumping through hoops to optimize that
there's also no state that I mentioned
that there's no state in the functions
they're designed for a shorter duration
that's how the billing model is out of
the box there's also no state I'm not
sure if I mentioned that
and putting together complex workflows
is
to put it bluntly complex so sorry to be
redundant but that's the reality and
there's no state by the way all right so
what's still hard with this well one of
these would be what I call a synchronous
sequential operations go out get
something wait for it come back get
something come back that's going to be
difficult to do in a cost-effective way
even more difficult is fan out and fan
in so I want to build a search engine
aggregator you put in your search term
in parallel I want to go out to Google
I'm sorry I work with Microsoft to being
then Google and this is in parallel Alta
Vista
Lykos some of the other servers I get
the results pull them back together call
another function to process it so that's
another pattern I may have this idea of
external events correlation so let's say
I have a process that has three steps
and I want to raise an event to say step
ones done step twos done steps three
done how do I manage that in code and in
serverless what if I have something
that's long-running that's doing
something interesting that I just want
to pull every once a while and ask it
where are you at how are things going
etc so this is a process that's ongoing
and its sole purpose is to provide me an
endpoint to get information maybe I have
a process that I kick off as a job
that's long-running
and I want to get the status of that job
and allow it to continue running but I
get that status in an asynchronous way
and then what if there's human
interaction let's say that I have a
customer service ticket come in and I
basically want someone to interact so
that triggers an event but if they don't
interact within a period of time I want
to automatically escalate that how do I
correlate those two things that timeout
wait and that human interaction so
durable functions are designed to
simplify everything I talked about
they're actually based on something
that's an open-source framework called
the durable task framework that exists
you can use it in dotnet applications
today there's just a specialized version
of that used to extend
as your functions on the agile platform
the way it works is we start with a
standard as your function that function
kicks off an Orchestrator function the
orchestrator is what's managing the
workflow you can have multiple workflows
you can also have nested workflows and
we'll look at that the orchestrator
function itself has some rules that
we'll get into so it's basically just
managing the workflow the steps within
the workflow are fanned out to what's
called activity functions activities are
what actually performs the work as part
of this orchestration so it looks sort
of like this the client kicks off the
orchestrator there's activities I may
have a sub Orchestrator that has its own
activities so some of the rules that
bind this whole engine is this idea of
reliable execution the way the
orchestrator works is when it goes to
sleep if something interesting happens
that wakes it back up it replays the
data to get to a certain point so it
needs to be reliable in that the same
input has the same output because it
uses these checkpoints that are at every
time it's waiting for something to
happen there's a checkpoint it saves and
plays back to so you need to have that
predictable workflow it saves a history
so that it can manage these checkpoints
it has to be deterministic if you do
something like if I roll dice and
randomly go to one activity or another
the orchestrator is going to fail
because it has to have a deterministic
path and we'll talk about how that's
managed but there are non-deterministic
steps right you have side-effects you're
going to update a database you're gonna
send a message you're gonna have
information that comes out as a result
so those are encapsulated within these
special types called activities the
orchestrator function needs to be
non-blocking it runs single threaded for
optimization so if I do an iteration or
I do a thread sleep 10,000 I'm basically
halting all of my orchestrators on that
particular process
because of this we don't await anything
just inside the orchestrator that's not
part of the orchestrator client the
client provides things that you can
inspect things that will kick off
activities those are what you await and
that's where the magic happens that it
automatically saves State and I'm
setting this context because we're gonna
go into code and it'll make a lot more
sense when you see it in action I
promise we can do things like have
infinite loops but I mentioned earlier
that there's an orchestration history so
how do we manage that the orchestrator
actually has a special function called
continue as new that allows that loop to
keep running and flushes the history
periodically and you determine when and
how that happens and the unit of work
and what we're doing is a durable task
and I'll show you what those look like
so this is my vision I I set out to
create a text-based adventure game
turned out it was pretty simple
basically you join a game you have two
minutes to confirm that you're really
committed to playing it if not you're
killed I'm sorry that's just the the way
it's set up you pick up a weapon you
slay a monster with the weapon the
monster drops a treasure you get the
treasure you win the game hopefully you
do that within a reasonable timeframe
but that's the whole point of this talk
is long-running stateful workflows so
what seems pretty simple can actually
look complicated when we put boxes and
lines together and say I'm an architect
now I've done a diagram but seriously
this is the new user flow what it's
going to do is kick off some parallel
jobs to create the universe then it's
going to kick off a monitor that checks
is the user still alive is a user still
alive etc it's also going to kick off an
orchestration waiting for the
confirmation so if we look inside that
confirmation that confirmation is going
to wait for that manual intervention yes
I'm committed to playing the game or if
two minutes is hit and there's no
confirmation it's just going to kill the
user
unfortunately there's the user monitor
checking to see is the user either dead
or have they won the game and then
there's a game set up the game set up
sequential
because we're dealing with table storage
and we need to do something like take an
inventory item put it on a monster put a
monster inside a room put a user inside
a room so instead of dealing with
complex concurrency we know that that
user is one workflow so we'll do that
sequentially and then finally we have a
game loop that is expecting two things
to happen to win the game killing the
monster and grabbing the treasure so
it's waiting on those two events so to
get started there's an extension it's
probably a newer version now but this is
the screenshot when I took it that you
basically pull in and you get packaged
and that pulls in the version of the
durable task framework frasier functions
and then this is a standard as your
function this is kicked off by an HTTP
trigger so it's very similar to what I
just showed you however if we dissect
this further we'll see that there's an
orchestration client that's injected
this is one of the bindings that then
allows me to control and interact
excuse-me interact with orchestrations
and i can do things like start a new
orchestration and pass it a piece of
information to uniquely identify that
orchestration it gets an ID but we
probably have some business data like a
inventory item number or in this case a
username that makes that workflow unique
and then that a weight doesn't
successfully wait for that orchestration
to run it just schedules it kicks it off
comes back says it's scheduled you're
good to go so you're not blocking your
function call so let's start a new game
what I'm going to do is I've got a
console that's running in the background
so that I can send some messages to it
that we monitor so I'm going to run that
it's a very simple connection string
connected to local storage right now and
then I'm going to go into my durable
dungeon and I'm gonna start this and
this is going to build and scan it and
this time when it looks inside the
project we're going to see it finds a
lot of endpoints a lot of workflows and
in api's as anyone here worked with htdp
repple by the way show hands so this is
an easy way to interact with endpoints
it's a global tool for dotnet core and
what I can do is use it to post and get
and interact with api's without pulling
up the UI for postman for example which
I'm sure a lot of people have used so
what I'm going to do is just set the
base URL that's how we start and when
you set the base URL in this case I
don't have this augmented with swagger
but if we did it would actually pull
swagger and figure out what the
characteristics of the API are but in
this case I'm just going to say post new
user so that's a function in point and I
have this configured to open up visual
studio code for me to write the payload
and a new user just has a name so we're
going to give the name Jan we'll save
that and close it and we get this 200 ok
if we come over to our console we can
see that there's a giant gigantic indigo
basilisk a spacious room was prepared
there's a hefty Morningstar a magic
diamond so we have all these cool
elements and now there's 2 minutes to
confirm we're ready so that kicks things
off so let's talk about what happened
first the orchestration client this is
able to start a new orchestration it's
able to get the status of a running
orchestration it's able to terminate a
running orchestration so if you have a
management console it's able to raise an
event so in form an orchestration that
something happened and it can also purge
the history for an instance so you can
do cleanup routines so the first thing
this create user thing did was these
parallel functions to create the
universe so I want to show you what that
looks like in code I'm going to come
back over here and first we have these
dungeon functions this is what kicks
things off let me just pull this in so
for a new user we have an HD
trigger we've got our console we've got
a table reference and we've got an
orchestration client so this is pulling
out the user it's going out to the table
to check to see if the user already
exists if the user exists that says we
got a problem there's already a user and
then it's kicking off to workflows so
this new user parallel functions and
this user monitor workflow so the
ongoing monitor for the user and then it
just says ok I think everything's fine
so when we look at the parallel user
workflow I've got these separated into
different files here's the main
orchestration piece so notice that it's
triggered with an orchestration trigger
just like we had an HTTP trigger this is
I'm getting the user name and then
here's a list of tasks create user
create monster create room create
inventory and I just do in a weight task
1 all keep in mind that each of these
tasks were called off of the context
remember I said we don't know wait for
anything that's not on the context and
then when it's done they cause a sub
Orchestrator that kicks off the
confirmation workflow so I'm doing that
as a sub workflow so what that means is
this parallel workflow won't end until
the confirmation workflow ends they're
tied together and this is just to
demonstrate how that works if we look at
a given activity these are the units of
tasks that can have side effects these
don't have to be deterministic so this
is triggered as an activity trigger it's
a table in a queue and this is literally
just going in and creating a user and
the bindings make my codes exists the
succinct and compact it's passed in I
basically get a client create the user
I'm done we do a similar thing to create
the monster to create the room and to
create the inventory so that's the the
parallel workflow and it just
automatically waits for all those
parallel functions to end and then it
continues through so the thing it does
as the sub workflow is this user
confirmation workflow that's setting a
timer
and then it's also waiting for human
interaction if we look at the code for
that I'm going to come into confirmation
functions and we've got user
confirmation workflow so again this is
kicked off with an orchestration trigger
we're getting the user and I'm calling
an activity to add something to a queue
because remember I can't await add to
the queue asynchronously myself because
I'm in an orchestration so I can wrap
that in an activity and that activity is
sending it into the console just for
information now here's how I'm doing a
time-out loop I'm basically creating a
cancellation token getting time off the
context this is what makes it
deterministic if I did date time UTC now
that would change with every run if I
get it off the context it's consistent
every time this orchestration flows
through so I get that I'm adding a
timespan I'm also waiting for this
approval event to happen and then I
create the timer and I'm waiting for
either thing to happen either get the
approval or the timer files fires so two
minutes or an approval if I got the
approval I cancel the timeout confirm
the user and then I kick off this
sequential workflow that we'll look at
in a minute otherwise I basically
timeout and I call an activity to kill
the user so if we look at our activities
I'm gonna skip over confirm user for now
kill user is basically just going out to
a table and it's setting the user is
alive to false it's a pretty pretty
simple way to kill the user so that's
what's in that workflow now if we go
back over to our console I've been
talking long enough that the workflow
kicked off and Jan has died because I've
spent too much time talking my two
minutes went up and it's game over for
Jan so having done that this is another
picture from the catacombs let's look at
status checking and some of the
internals of how we got to where we're
at
so what I can do in my htdp repple is I
can and I'm just going to steal this
from a webpage so you don't have to see
me fumbling with typing and we're gonna
do user actually I will fumble with
typing user confirmation user monitor so
we're gonna get check status part of the
path is a username and then user
confirmation workflow that's going to
call out to the endpoint comes back it
tells me that that's a completed process
and the other one is the user what was
the user Monitor workflow does a similar
thing if we look at the code for this
this is going to be in Dungeon functions
once again the entry point is just a
standard trigger HTTP trigger I'm
checking on the status of this user what
I do is I have a helper job that sends
out a Corian says give me the instances
that have this workflow name and this
user and then it just simply queries the
status and returns it so that's how we
can do that ongoing set of basically
checking status and monitoring it now
behind the scenes a few things have
happened if I jump into my storage
Explorer and I open up my tables we can
see that there's this durable functions
hub history and that's a history of
everything that's happened up to this
point which is quite a bit of history
for a short time talking and then we
have these instances that show that
there were a total of three workflows
and they're all completed so behind the
scenes durable functions creates a set
of control queues and a set of tables to
keep track of history store checkpoints
and ensure that the orchestrations are
running correctly and that's what we
quarry behind the scenes and then you
can see I've created sort of the
elements of my universe here there's the
inventory there's the monster and these
are partitioned
user and then have keys based on what
the items are so that's a little bit
behind the scenes for that now just as
an aside one of the advantages you get
from using durable functions is some
advanced error handling so you can use
trycatch within your code that's
perfectly fine
as long as it's in a deterministic way
you're not rolling dice within the block
any failure inside an activity will
throw an exception so the orchestrator
will receive an exception from that and
if the exceptions not caught the
workflow is going to end with a failed
status that you can query for and look
into however you can manage your
activities you can set up when you call
those async activities without changing
the code of your activity it might be
updating a table doing something like
that you can setup retries and retry
interval a back off interval a timeout
you can even create a function that
it'll call back and say should I retry
again or not so you have some
flexibility with that this is an example
of what that would look like here we're
saying if it doesn't work try again
after five seconds and try it a maximum
of three times and then we're calling it
with that retry and if you don't like
flaky function pass as a magic string as
long as it's in something that you can
access from types from the code you can
do the name of right and then pass it as
a solid reference so let's look at
sequential workflow monitoring with the
user that we don't let die let's
actually create a user that survives the
process so I'm going to come back to
host new user that's going to pop up in
Visual Studio again and this time let's
make a user named Emma I'm gonna save
that and close so I get my okay if I go
to my console it's showing me that it's
created the user and we're waiting for
confirmation so I'm gonna go ahead and
post that confirmation so I'm going to
post confirm user
and it's the same structure I basically
pass it the name save that and close
that if we look at our console we see
we've accepted the challenge and now
it's giving us some context she's
standing in a room there's broken
pottery the user confirmation workflows
complete there's a glowing mace there's
a glowing red Gorgon or growling red
Gorgon so glowing mace growling Gorgon
and M is alive but hasn't found the
treasure yet so let's walk through what
happened when I confirm so the first
thing it did was kicked off a sequential
workflow so we created the inventory the
monster the room but we didn't tie
anything together until Emma made the
commitment the code for that looks like
this we've got a confirm user which is
just an HCP trigger and that's going to
come in and it's going to do some things
like make sure the users there make sure
the user is alive if everything looks
good and it's got the confirmation
workflow because it wants to know it's
running
remember the workflow was waiting for
either the timeout to fire or for that
event to come that the user confirmed
this is how we send the message that
they confirmed we go out we grab that
that client so we give it the username
this is here and the name of the
workflow when we grab that workflow we
just raise an event called approval toss
true so that's what we did we just sent
to that user confirmation workflow and
said yes they're approved so if we go
back to the user confirmation workflow
if it gets that message right here so
it's waiting for either the approval or
the timeout if it gets the approval it's
starting a new workflow called
sequential user workflow
it's over here and it's gonna be a
little anti-climatic
after seeing the fan out fan in we're
just simply awaiting in sequence so
we're saying basically put the user in
the room but the inventory in the room
put the monster in the room give the
monster the treasure and now start a new
workflow that monitors the game so we
only kick off that game monitor workflow
if the user commits and we can come back
to our repple and we can do a check
status this time we'll do Emma and the
user monitor workflow is running because
she's still alive she hasn't died and
she hasn't won the game we also now have
a game monitor workflow and that is also
running so speaking of that user monitor
workflow and game monitor workflow I
have two different long-running
workflows to show you two different ways
that you can do this with durable
functions I'm gonna come back over to
the code and go back into monitor
functions and the first thing we'll look
at is the monitor user so the monitor
user comes out make sure it's a valid
user and it's checking so this is an
activity basically to see did the user
get the treasure did anything
interesting happen and it's just sending
out information to the console based on
that if we look at the user Monitor
workflow this is setting up an expiry
time and it's actually checking every 20
seconds how's the game status going so
we basically monitor the user while
we're not timed out so I didn't want
this to run infinitely if someone
accidentally left it on so it runs for
an hour hopefully we're not here an hour
from now
so it'll timeout automatically and then
it's just setting up a next check and
creating a timer so it says 20 seconds
let's check again 20 seconds let's check
again we're an hour out we're just going
to give up and it's check check check if
we timeout we in
we in the function and we basically tell
you it's either timed out or it's done
and if it's done it's because the user
won the game and this check right here
returns a boolean so it's true if
everything's done false if it's not
and it'll be true if the user dies or if
the user gets the treasure so that's one
way to do it so that's on a timer every
20 seconds how's the game going
there's another way that we can do this
and that's the game monitor workflow and
the game monitor workflow is waiting for
two events killing the monster and
getting the treasure so we just set up a
wait for those external events and we do
a weight task when all and it's as
simple as that it's just going to wait
and unless those two events come in the
game maunder workflow is just going to
keep running now I could have done the
timer if I want the timeout I could also
have another function that will go out
and kill the the workflow but right now
this workflow is just perpetually
waiting for those two events to come in
and we'll look at how those events come
in in a second if we look at our table
that was set up now if we refresh this
you're gonna see there's a monster is
alive true and we've got some inventory
items right here so it's got a warm
diamond if we look at the room the room
now is going to if I scroll over you can
see that the user or the monster and the
inventory item are placed in the room so
everything's tied together and the games
in a state ready and waiting for
something interesting to happen I'm sure
you're waiting for something interesting
to happen too so let's go ahead and in
this game we have a few steps to make
that happen first thing I'm going to do
is have Emma pick up the weapon so I'm
just getting the template for this and
of course all this code is open source
and I'm showing you the walkthrough so
you can do this on your own and I'm just
going to come back and do a reality
check it's a glowing mace so if I'm
gonna post to my action in point
and my action is to have Emma get the
glowing mace so we'll save that close
out if we go to our console successfully
grab the glowing mace you see that at
the bottom so the next thing we need to
do is kill the monster with the mace so
we have a little bit more complex
command here I'm going to post to my
action this time I'm going to do a kill
action
the target is a growling indigo was a
basilisk growling red Gorgon and instead
of the magic mace we're doing it with
the glowing mace which I'm not quite
sure what the difference is apparently
the magic mace is a little more magical
than the glowing one that's my best
guess for you so we'll do that again
okay we pop over to our console so we
valiantly killed the glowing red Gorgon
and they dropped a worn diamond so the
last task and I'll let everyone here
sort out how a diamond gets worn but it
could happen so we're going to name Emma
action get and our target this time is a
worn diamond I was really hoping for the
bloody Commodore 64 that's my favorite
treasure but alas the randomness did not
align and it helps if I close out so it
actually posts so we get an OK and it
says it's won the game but what's
interesting is right now the game
monitor is done because it got it's too
events now you can see Emma's won the
game finally mo monitoring's done so
that kicked off a little later because
that was on a timer and now if we look
at our status for our different
workflows let's go back into our hub
instances we can see we had a lot more
workflows for Emma but everything is
completed there's nothing running
so everything's concluded and closed out
so I want to just show you how we raise
the the message and then we'll cover a
couple other points so if we go inside
to dungeon functions this is where we
have our actions actually action
functions makes more sense right I named
these actually quite well so this is
again an HCP trigger and what it's going
to do is it's going to take all the
information in its parsing out is the
user actually there's the user alive
does the monster exists is the the
inventory that the user is trying to get
there's a get method if the actions kill
there's a kill method and if we look at
the let's look at the get method first
so the get method is simply a method
that I can call directly from within
code there's nothing special this isn't
a service endpoint it's just an internal
method that I'm calling to separate out
code but what it's doing is it's
checking the target seeing if the room
has the target grabbing the target and
the key thing to look at is if what Emma
grabbed is a treasure it's going to tell
us that the user nabbed the treasure and
it's going to go find that game monitor
workflow because there's one running for
him as game and it's gonna raise the
event got treasure so that's the first
event that it's waiting for otherwise
it's gonna say target not found or tried
to get target that doesn't exist
the monster logic also has to figure out
does the user have the weapon is the
monster in the room did we name the
monster correctly is the monster
actually still alive because you could
try to kill it twice and it'll come back
with a snarky tried to kill a ghost but
if it's alive and everything pans out
it's going to do a similar thing where
it's going to update the table mark the
user or mark the monster is dead and
then it's finding that game monitor
workflow again and it's raising that
event.kill monster
so it's signaling into the event that
can happen now that's how that code
works there's a another open source
project that you can find a link out to
it that's part of the Microsoft ignite
tour this is a tour that was after the
ignite event and we had a server list
module where we did a more corporate
focused example and this is a skew and a
skew is an inventory item and it has a
lifetime so you can add a SKU to a
catalog but then there's some
expectations the SKU needs to have its
price correctly set and needs to have a
description and needs have an image and
it needs all these things to happen
before it can be active and visible in
the catalogue and so that example uses a
long running workflow like this to wait
for those events to happen and it
actually uses a vent grid which is a
messaging service to send those messages
in and it just relays them it gets the
message okay the description was added
let me find the workflow for the SKU and
raise the event to the SKU that that
description was added so that's how that
workflow works so as a summary of what I
showed you with these orchestration
contexts we're only awaiting on tasks
derived by the context if we try to wait
on something else the orchestration will
actually throw an exception because
it'll detect that it's non-deterministic
because you're waiting something it
doesn't have control over there is a
flag on the context that if you have
something like you want to log something
only the first time it kicks off you can
check is replay and because the logging
doesn't have a side-effect except in the
log itself which it's not a side-effect
in the workflow or the state that's
acceptable so if is replay will do this
thing
you can kick off new orchestrations but
you have to do them inside of activities
and I'm not sure why
they don't put this on the orchestration
trigger the ability to create a new
orchestration but they don't so if you
try to wait and bring in an
orchestration binding you're not
awaiting on the context it's going to
throw an exception but you can have an
activity that you await on the activity
and tell the activity to kick off the
orchestration and that works fine and
date/time is only real on your context
you got to get used to if you're
checking time you check context get UTC
date as opposed to day time now so
there's some advanced concepts that come
around this there is the possibility of
cross app communication so if I have
multiple orchestrators and different
function apps I can set up and this is
using a pretty straightforward HTTP set
of requests so it's using an HCP
endpoint basically to kick off another
Orchestrator and then it's going out and
getting the status but you could use
cues you can use messaging there's other
ways to communicate between
orchestrations the way orchestrations
work is there's a concept called
partitions that orchestrations are
scaled across there's a default of four
you can configure it up to sixteen on a
host and then you can also run multiple
hosts and scale across hosts and there's
guidance in the documentation for that
you can also throttle concurrency so you
can determine how many requests certain
set of partitions can handle at the same
time and then there's this concept
called extended sessions now I talked
about the checkpoint and the replay so
every time it's coming in it's replaying
all these messages up to a certain point
you may have a process that times out in
30 seconds and it's doing a check and
doing that well if you don't set up an
extended session it's still going to
replay even in that short period of time
if I can figure that to be an extended
session it'll say okay what they're
telling me is we can keep this in memory
and just wait in memory and not hydrate
everything to disk and basically
override the default behavior so you get
less history and you get a little bit
more performance out of that now I
talked about high availability basically
everything is managed through a storage
account so the queues the backing tables
are in a storage account you can create
a globally redundant storage account so
that redundancy is built into how you
set up the storage account you could
have multiple orchestrations in
different regions using a storage
account that's not globally redundant
and then that becomes your point of
failure but if you have a geo redundant
storage and you have geo redundant
orchestrations they're all kept in sync
because they're talking to the same
storage client and it's handling that
replication behind the scenes for you
for performance and scale numbers this
is more it's not as interesting in the
talk but I wanted this in the deck for
you to refer to there's a performance
target of five sequential activities per
second per instance this is assuming
that it's a reasonably returned activity
obviously if the activity itself takes a
minute but if you ever return directly
from the activity this is the the level
fan-out 100 per second per instance this
kind of helps you based on the volume of
controllers you're bringing through
durable functions figure out partitions
and if you need multiple function apps
running and then you can actually unit
test these now this is a little bit
dated I apologize for not updating this
but it was a rabbit hole I didn't want
to go through at the last minute but the
newer version actually goes away from
these base clients to interfaces but
originally if you're using the the
version here you can mock a base class
and you can set up expectations you can
create a mock logging mechanism you can
create a mock orchestration status
response so you can fully unit test it
and the newer version uses interfaces so
you even have more flexibility with
mocking those interfaces now before I
dive into the the summary I did create a
utility because all of these are API is
that you can access over HTTP so I
created a very simple front-end I'm
going to take full credit for the UI
design I added a
both fonts and padding tags myself I'm
very proud of this I don't want anyone
to freak out if you look at the the
source code for this because this will
run and give you a front-end that
interacts with everything but if we look
at the code what you're gonna find is
there's a disturbing lack of any fancy
JavaScript framework just using vanilla
jazz so it's just straightforward
JavaScript and we're using these things
that some people who have lived and died
in angular and react might not even know
there's a good element by ID but you can
walk through this this code base I tried
to keep it simple but this basically
it's showing the status of the different
workflows allows me to enter user so I'm
going to use the handle that I used to
use when I played doom and quake back in
the day which was Nicodemus and when I
start typing it it starts monitoring and
they turn grey because it's unknown
status right now I haven't done anything
interesting so I can create a new user
and all of a sudden you see the user
monitor and the run user parallel
workflow those kick off and the universe
is now waiting for Nicodemus so it's
waiting for the confirmation so I can
come here and notice that the user
confirmation workflow kicked off so I'll
click confirm and now these turn red
because these workflows are done and now
we've got the user in the game monitor
workflow running and we've got some
context here we can see the description
of the room there's a moaning indigo
troll so that would be interesting to
put up with right alright this is we're
getting better with the treasure though
there's a magic zark trilogy set which
I'm pretty excited about and we're back
to a glowing hack so I'm not sure what
that's all about but let's go ahead and
get the glowing axe
okay now I'm holding on to the glowing
axe so now I can kill and I could say
something with something else just to
show you that it actually handles these
cases action failed user doesn't have
something else it only has the glowing
axe so let's go ahead and kill the
moaning indigo troll with the glowing
axe and it drops the magic Zork trilogy
set so let's get the magic Zork trilogy
set and we won the game so this code
will show you how with all those end
points that I was manually posting to
you could architect an application
around those end points and workflows
and work with them that way
so to recap this code gives you examples
of the a synchronous sequential
workflows fan out and fan in external
eventing there's a couple examples of
that a long-running game monitor a
long-running API that game monitor runs
for a long period of time but you can
pull it and check status and then that
human interaction that timeout and
escalation so all these elements are
available I've got I'll actually tweet
out the link to the full deck but these
are the main links for what I covered
here it's the emulator they explore the
durable functions and if you go to the
github repo that repo has step-by-step
instructions to set everything up and
walk through that we've got about three
minutes so what I'm gonna do is go ahead
and close out but I'll stay for any
questions that you have you can always
feel free to email me and talk to me
thank you once again for spending the
end of your first day at in DC with me I
appreciate everyone
[Applause]